the Supreme Courts here are his
arguments this morning on a significant
case focusing on race and voting rights
in Alabama the court opens its new term
yesterday with two black justices for
the first time ever catanji Brown
Jackson joining Clarence Thomas Jan
Crawford is at the Supreme Court where
the justices are poised to make more
historic rulings in the coming year Jan
good morning good morning you know after
that Blockbuster term last year they're
back taking on more contentious cases
this year on issues like race gay race
discrimination and they are jumping
right in with a major case from Alabama
later this morning on the Voting Rights
Act
in 1965 during the struggle for voting
rights this was the epicenter Selma
Alabama today's Selma is again at the
center of a battle over voting this room
is called the foot soldiers Hall of Fame
Sam Walker is head of the National
Voting Rights Museum at the foot of the
Edmund Pettus bridge this is the actual
voting machine that black people voted
on when they voted back in 1966 at the
signing of the Voting Rights Act of
August of 1965 but now with black voter
registration at historic highs black
leaders say Alabama is using
redistricting to dilute the power of
their vote and their ability to elect
officials of their choice in violation
of the Voting Rights Act here in Alabama
we feel that you know the white
Community has never really represented
the black interest the state is 27
percent black but only one of Alabama's
seven congressional districts which
includes Soma is majority black now
represented by Alabama's only Democratic
representative congresswoman Terry
Sewell having a congressional
representation that's responsive to the
needs of those communities is very
important Evan Milligan who grew up in
Alabama and now leased the group Alabama
forward sued saying the state should
have two black districts and that his
organization has shown how it can be
done if I know that I I'm voting in a
district where no matter how many times
I come to vote for certain seats my vote
doesn't matter because of how the
district has been drawn then there's
little incentive for me to to
participate that is the district in
question but Secretary of State John
Merrill says the only way to possibly
create two black districts is to focus
solely on Race which Alabama argues
shouldn't even be a consideration it
says the the Voting Rights Act requires
States draw districts neutrally what the
legislature attempted to do is to draw
impartial districts that were unbiased
not according to race and he says
creating two geographically compact
districts would risk decreasing black
representation by taking some black
voters from the one safe District which
is now about 57 percent black the
likelihood of there being seven white
members of Congress instead of six
whites and one African-American
increases dramatically
now Alabama lost in the lower court but
the Supreme Court put that decision on
hold so Alabama can use its map for the
elections next month this case will
affect future elections not only in
Alabama but in States across the country
Nate
Jan thank you